HBM the greatest network of our time has
brought you compelling documentaries
about pimps hoes players John's tricks
marks mark Asterix ragazze marks
skeezers Frank's kicks gags and Scully
wops now America's most incredible
network gives you another side of the
story as we go into the world of the
haters America undercover presents the
player haters ball yeah you know I'm
saying like real hatin man that's like
an art form man you know it's like you
you like a born and hater you know like
myself man you know a lot of cats think
they hate but man I mean I'm mad you
know I'm mad at everything man you know
brother got a nice car man why you got a
car man I only got one car while you got
away you got three cars or a wife or all
that man and that's played out man I
hate on it till he's totally broke ain't
got nothing like me you know I'm saying
cuz I yeah that's what real Haden is all
about man it was popular me by the evil
star hate when I welcome you to the
fifth annual player haters award
ceremony this gala affair we are we host
this once a year we honor the most
prestigious verbal abusers on the planet
free hater from career your bitches
better recognize
Sibella ma dong maharaja he looks like a
broke-ass sexual chakra the player
haters ball interest an opportunity to
hit on a diverse array of mawkish locks
triggers most punk bitches and skip stop
skanks and scallywags hoes heifers
hee-haws and hula hoops man you want to
take that cane and beat whoever made
that suit the devil vacuum that Copeman
well the most diabolical haters this
side of the Mississippi but Lisa what
can I say about this suit that hasn't
already been said about Afghanistan it
looks bombed out and depleted and of
course the so-called beautiful why don't
you click the heels together three times
and go back to Africa very insulting
what you said about my coat it's made
out of your mother's pubic hair right
now if you'll excuse me I'm gonna go
take my throne cuz I'm a shoo-in for
hater of the year the player haters ball
is not always about hating on one
another we play games with the other
tunes like our annual photo flip Oh
always said it doesn't want anyone to
see him shine but the looks shiny to me
necks before converted to his fame Thank
You Michelle I've been led to pump my
gas in my car they'll be running because
I take yoga classes from my ex picture
please I like the song the girl sings
Papa don't preach I got a song for you
to which it's called daughter don't sing
[Music]
Boy George
she wears underwear with dick holes in
them
[Applause]
war for player-hater out of here iced
tea
I like to welcome all you ignorant ass
bitches critics complainers disgruntled
rappers and races especially to the 9th
annual international player haters ball
oh man man you corny next taste them
while I'm talking is getting shot please
do
[Applause]
so without further ado let me give you
the nominations for player hater of the
year
y'all ready first up but nasty but Nancy
is nominated for getting his best
friend's wife pregnant then tricking his
best friend and to raise in the little
the next nominee is pit boi is nominated
for calling the police on the drug
dealers the move next door to his house
not because it was the right thing to do
just because he was jealous of all the
money they was making good one and only
silky Johnson silky Johnson is nominated
for calling in a bomb threat to the
Special Olympics man winner the 9th
annual player hater of the Year award is
silky John stay
Sukie meeting made out of 100% red ass
hit me baby
[Music]
beautiful token beautiful on the
weekends does stunts for Little Richard
and gay movies first off I would like to
thank God Almighty
we're giving everybody so much and me so
little hate you I hate you I don't even
know you
and I hate your guts I hope all the bad
things in life happen to you with nobody
else but you
and as I sip my soda that I'm sure
somebody spit in I just would like to
say to all of you kiss my ass you rotten
excuse me I'm gonna go home and put some
water in buck masters momma's dish good
evening
[Applause]